attention et on commence par là une donc
c'est terrible à tant que thierry énorme
et on tire la langue pour finir bien sûr
attention pour thierry et non d'abord
c'est de sevelnord a d'abord 3 2 1
c'est quoi qu'est ce que c'est alors
montrer ce qu'est ce que des non passif
il assure éric assez bon et le film
serait la dose et gilles nos régimes
celle là c'est la 2 ça va bouger
attention attention à croquer c'est bon
[ __ ] de merde mais bordel
[Applaudissements]
on n'attendait pas d'ailleurs
attendez attendez attendez attendez
attendez dans l'attenté matelas
s'empilent se situe la nuit on pouvait
marcher qu'un petit morceau rap affaire
comme dans koh lanta exactement mais
attention et laurent attendait et n'aura
besoin d'eau qui s'écoule et nora et
d'europe rien y'a une poubelle de verre
alors attention
gilles fitou
[Applaudissements]